I wanted to be married for life and I
wanted to have kids and the whole thing
same as you yes so when that didn't
happen I just I went you know it was
really hurtful but going through you
know rehab and there's this fourth step
where you you write down all your
resentments and he said you know in a in
a in a row I said give me that pin ah
she did this to me she did that blah and
he said now in the next column what part
did you play on all that I said I okay
he said even if it was 1% right I start
writing and I realized that I had a lot
more to do with it than I thought and
anything less than truth is paralysis
and that's what I realized here and it
feels good to just get it out and say
I'm sorry for things I I I'm sorry for
and um but I learned and I if I hadn't
had this Rocky stuff I I wouldn't have
the fairy tale life that I have now